all right did you guys know that it was
shark week yeah yeah all right pancho's
mexican restaurant is celebrating with a
shark attack
cocktail that is so let's welcome
bartender jason watkins to the show just
to
you know tell us how dangerous this
drink really is what's in the drink oh
it's buzz it's worse than it's bite let
me tell you
uh we are so excited for shark week and
we just want to start by saying thank
you so much to the community
uh everyone has been great during this
crazy year and we couldn't be more
humbled
and we feel really blessed to have a
community behind us
but yes it is shark week it's an
exciting week for us and i'd love to
share this cocktail with you
um so yeah let's get started are we
beginning
nice spiced rum
we pour nicely here so a good two ounce
pour on that
oh i get what it's called chocolate
chips
uh tropico and ocean like coconut rum so
that gets a nice layer
our house made pineapple juice
absolutely delicious
so fresh and a little blue orange look
here on top
oh yes
and of course no drink is complete with
a beautiful garnish
and that is our shark attack cocktail
we have a lot of exciting things going
on our happy hour is one of the best in
town
and of course you don't know us we are
located in beautiful downtown summerlin
our happy hour is monday through friday
uh two to seven and all day long on the
weekends from
open until uh 7 p.m we also do half off
tequila on sundays from three to close
including a beautiful brunch all right
jason thank you so much the drink is
beautiful and i know that it's available
all year round not just for shark week
so everybody got to go down to panchos
and enjoy
that food and the drinks we appreciate
you
thank you so much all right happy shark
week everybody